Here's a figure that
illustrates the relationship between polynomial and exponential cost.
On the X axis, we have the input length to whatever problem we're thinking about, and the Y axis represents the
cost of solving that problem
or you can think about
it as the time required to solve the problem if you prefer.
An exponential cost algorithm
might scale like this.
For short inputs, the cost might not be particularly high, like factoring the
number 12, for instance,
but as the input length gets longer, the cost is eventually going to blow up.
A polynomial cost algorithm,
on the other hand, might have a scaling that looks like this.
The cost will still increase in general as inputs get longer, and it might even cost more than the exponential cost
algorithm for some inputs,
but eventually it's gonna
be a lot less expensive than the exponential cost algorithm and it doesn't blow up
in the same extreme way
that exponential cost algorithms do.
So if we imagine that we
have some maximum cost that we're willing to spend, or a maximum amount of time that we're willing to wait for an answer,
if you prefer to think about time, then the exponential cost algorithm will only work for inputs
up to a given length,
whereas, in general, the
polynomial cost algorithm will allow us to solve the
problem for larger inputs.
And that's why, for instance, we can easily compute GCDs for numbers with many thousands of
bits, but in the worst case,
we can't factor numbers of this size.
In the last part of the lesson, we'll turn our attention to implementing classical computations
on quantum computers.
More specifically, we'll
see that any computation that can be performed by a Boolean circuit can also be performed by a quantum circuit
at roughly the same cost. Moreover, this can be
done in a clean manner that's important if we
wanna run these computations
as sub routines inside of
larger quantum computations, and I'll explain what I mean by clean when we get further into the discussion.
We're going to make use of
Toffoli gates in this process.
Recall that Toffoli gates are controlled-controlled-NOT gates, so their action on standard basis states
is as you see here on the screen.
Notice that we can also
think about Toffoli gates as being like query gates
for the AND function.
That's not to say that they are query gates in a literal sense. As I mentioned at the start of the lesson, we're not working within the
query model at this point,
but rather, their action follows the same pattern as a query gate.
We can think of the binary values A and B as the inputs to the AND function and like a query gate,
these values get echoed
as part of the output and the value of the function, meaning the logical AND of A and B
gets XORed onto the bottom qubit. Now, we haven't included Toffoli gates in our standard gate set.
We could change our mind if we wanted to, but we don't really need to
do that because alternatively, we can implement Toffoli
gates using Hadamard gates,
T and T dagger gates
and controlled NOT gates like you see right here.
It's not at all obvious
that this particular circuit implements a Toffoli gate, but it does, and you can either take my word for it
or multiply everything out for yourself to get some extra practice, or you can just ask Qiskit or Python
or any software that multiplies matrices to do the multiplication for you.
And you can check out the
textbook content for the lesson to see this done using Qiskit.
Now we can move on to simulating Boolean gates with quantum circuits and all we'll need to
do this are NOT gates,
controlled NOT gates and Toffoli gates.
These operations are all deterministic in addition to being unitary and sometimes we describe
operations like this as being reversible, and in fact,
the study of reversible computation predates quantum computing and that's where this entire
procedure actually comes from.
The Boolean gates we need to
worry about are NOT gates, Hadamard gates and FANOUT gates,
And what we're going to show is that we can implement these gates, or simulate them if you
prefer, using NOT gates,
controlled NOT gates and Toffoli gates.
To be clear, what we
want are quantum circuits that allow us to compute the values of the Boolean gates that I just mentioned
when we give them qubits in
standard basis states as input.
For arbitrary quantum state inputs, the action will be determined
by linearity as usual.
We don't need to do anything
special with the NOT gates. NOT gates are NOT gates and they can be implemented directly.
And OR gates can be simulated
using Toffoli and NOT gates.
AND gates are easy, particularly in light of what I just said a few moments ago about Toffoli gates being essentially
query gate implementations
of the AND function.
To be precise, what we can do is to introduce a new qubit initialized to the zero state
and let that qubit be the
target of our Toffoli gate and let the two input
qubits be the controls.
Different names are given
to extra qubits like this, which are often introduced
into quantum computations and I'll call them workspace
qubits just to pick a name.